me
[音楽]
こんにちは
北海道大学で風景の研究をしている
山崎と申します本日は風景のない街というタイトルで少しだけお話しさせていただき
たいなと思います
早速なんですけど皆さんは風景と聞いてどのような場面を想像しますか
頭に思い浮かべてみてください
風景という言葉は非常にいろいろな場面で使える言葉です
例えば山の風景とか街の風景
農村の風景それから会議の風景とか
仲の良い親子の風景とか
そんないろんなときに使える風景という言葉ですが最初に頭に思い浮かべたのはどの
ような場面だったでしょうか
試しに世界中の言葉で風景と検索してみるとこのようにいろいろな写真が出てきます
その中には多くが自然の風景で一部は街の風景などもありますが
これらほぼすべてが
際立った特徴のある風景だというふうに見れるのではないでしょうか
もう一つ同じような実験をしてみたいと思います
皆さんは札幌と聞いてどのような場面をイメージしますか
札幌に最近住んだ人大学に来てから住んだ人
また生まれてからずっと住んだ人とかによっても違うかもしれません
これも同じような方法で札幌の持つイメージを解き明かしてみたいと思います
これを見ると時計台とかテレビ塔から見る大通公園とか
札幌駅とか羊ヶ丘展望台とか
特徴的な札幌の風景というものがここには多く出ているのではないでしょうか
ここでもう一度風景という言葉が持つ意味について考えてみました
辞書を見ると目の前に広がる眺めというのが風景の持つ意味として出てきます
また
風景が9社の第12者の方は風景というものを人間の視点からみた土地の姿というふう
に定義しています
このことからどこに立ってもそこから見る目の前に広がる風景は広がる場面のことは
風景というふうに呼べるということが分かりますけれども
多くの人がイメージしたものまたは風景と言って検索して出てくる結果というものは
際立った風景だったのではないでしょうか
実際に札幌の風景といっても色々な風景があります
一部入れ替えて
表現してみました
このなかには住宅地の風景や小学校の周り
幹線道路のロードサイドや駅のもありなどさまざまな風景が含まれています
けれども実際に多くの人がイメージする風景というものは際立った風景という実態が
あるのかなというふうに考えています
ここで一つエピソードを紹介したいと思います
私は風景を研究している研究者です
5年間かけてさまざまな風景を研究してきました
その中で風景がどのような影響を受けて
できてきたかということを解き明かしています
僕の研究のやり方は町の役場の方
例えば市役所の方などにお話しを伺ってその風景の背景にある原因というものを
解き明かすということをしていますある時に町の役場に行って風景を研究している山崎
と申します
あなたの街の取り組みについてお
お伺いしたいんですけどと言うことを聞くと
うちの街には風景なんてないよと返されたことがありました
これはどういう意味だったのかということを後からよく考えました
その時はすごく強い疑問を持ちました風景のない街なんてあるのかな
実際に風景という言葉が際立った風景のことを多くの場合対象としています
なのであまり観光地にはなっていないような街ですとうちの街には風景はないよという
言葉に表れたのかなと考えました
けれども多くの場合街には住んでいる人がいますしいろいろな場所に働いている人がい
ます
その場所はその人にとっては
とても住環境や働きやすさに関わる風景だと思います
また観光の人にとっても決して観光地だけを巡るということは不可能ですその移動の
家庭には様々な風景が含まれます
それなのに風景際立った風景だけが取り上げられるということに少し疑問を持ちました
そこから私は
ありふれた風景を対象として研究を行うようになりました
これは私が5年間取り組んできたありふれた風景を対象とした研究のイメージパース
です
このずに含まれているシーンは例えば幹線道路沿いにお店が並んでいたり
その看板が出ていたり
または山から川が流れてきて農村まで
流れ下りたり
工場がところどころに点在しているそんなよくあるありふれた風景だというふうに思い
ます
ありふれた風景を研究するというと
すごくとらえどころがないように聞こえるかもしれませんので
どのような方法を使ってその研究を行ってきたかということを少しだけお話ししたいな
というふうに思います
これは
どこだかわかる人いらっしゃるでしょうか実は右下に小さく書いてあるんですけど
恵庭市の漁川という彼はです水道の水源にもなっている
大事な川です
彼はは日本に3万5千本あると言われています
当たり前のことですがその全てが高い所から低い所に流れています
その中には森の中を流れたり街の中を流れたり
農村の中を流れたり様々な風景がその周りには広がっています
そこで私の研究では彼はの周りにあるありふれた風景を解き明かすために川にかかる橋
から見た風景に着目しました
これが実際に橋が架かっているところをポイントしています
橋は人が通る場所です橋からは風景を見ることができます
川の風景だけじゃなくて彼はの周りの風景も見ることができます
実際の研究では
すべての橋の上流方向と下流方向にこうやってパノラマ写真を撮影していきました
ちょっと変わった人に見られたかもしれません
そのパノラマ写真の中にどのような要素が含まれているかということを丹念に見ていき
ます
例えばこの例ですとここには集合住宅がここには工作物がここには公園があるなどと
言ったように一つ一つの写真から丁寧に何が風景を構成している要素かということを
読み解いて
いきました
すべての端にすべての写真について行ったところを色々な風景がありました
例えばカラフルな住宅街
ヒマワリを植えているのお知
草がぼうぼうの森など本当に様々な風景が見れました
ここから何がありふれた風景を構成している要素なのかということを
みたところだいたいこの5つが多く見られるということが分かりました僕の研究では
これらすべてについてじっくり
何が影響しているか
どういう実態になっているかということを見ていますがその一例を紹介したいなという
ふうに
これはある橋から撮った写真なんですけれども
護岸と言われる川のすぐそばにある場所の整備の仕方が右と左で違うということが
わかっていただけるかなというふうに思いますこの整備の仕方はなぜ生まれたのかと
いうことに着目しますか
向かって右側は住宅がたくさん立ち並んでいます
住宅がたくさん立っているということは多くの人が住んでいる場所です
人が住む上では例えば憩う場所とか皮に触れ合う場所というものを求める場合があり
ます
この階段状になっている護岸の整備というものは人が川に近づけるために作った後がん
です
では左側はどういう目的があるのかというと
彼はというのは人間だけじゃなくてたとえば魚とか
野鳥とかいろんな生き物が住む場所になっています
恵庭の漁川は野鳥が多く飛んでくるかはだそうです
そういうときにはここに鳥が巣を作れる目的で
木をたくさん生やす橋善方の護岸を作るという場合があります
つまり風景を目的にはしていないさまざまな取り組みが風景を形作っているということ
です
その風景に変化が現れます
もう一つえーを紹介させてもらいたいと思います
これも
違う場所で僕が取り組んだ研究プロジェクトです
これは
どこかわかる方もいるかもしれませんが帯広犬です
帯広県は十勝農業王国十勝の真ん中にある
中心都市です
なので中心都市に求められる求められる役割の1つに農業を盛り上げるということが
ありますそのためにこの赤く塗ってあるマル一つ一つは農業を盛り上げるのに関わって
いる工場です
このぐらいたくさんの棒状があります実際どのぐらいあるかというと
50個あります逆
この約50個の向上すべてを一つ一つ写真をとってもありました
そんな観光客いないと思いますね50個の向上を一つ一つ見て回ってそれぞれどういう
風景の実態があるか
どのぐらい建物が建っているかどういう印象を受けるかといったことを調査していき
ました
例えば建物はどのぐらいの面積なのか
なんとぐらい経っているのか
こういうことを見ることで帯広の中に工場はありふれた要素としてたくさん建っている
んですけどもありふれた要素の中にある違いのようなものを発見しました
具体的に言うと街の中にある工場と農村の中にある工場ではその特徴が違うということ
などを把握しています
ん
具体例一つだけ紹介させてもらいたいと思います
これは畑の中にある工場です
通常建物は建築関係の方はわかるかと思うんですけれども
1敷地に市立ものというのが原則ですけれども
畑の中にある工場はこれ全部ほぼ一市敷地なんですけれどもその中に複数の建物が建っ
ているという現状がありました
これはなぜかということを発見していくのが僕の研究です
いろいろな理由がありましたけれどもその中の例えば一つ
農業に関する質向上は補助金をもらって立てているものがたくさんあります
補助金の中には補助してあげるけどその建物を建てた後は壊さないで使ってねという
決まり事があるものも多くあります
その決まり事に基づいて作られた工場というものは壊せない
壊すことが難しいのでどんどん周りに新しい建物を足していきます最初はここだけだっ
たのが次はここに次はここに次はここにというようにどんどん施設が増えていくことで
このように横に立ち並んだような工場の風体が
農村の中に出来上がるという特徴があるということを明らかにしました
これらの研究で僕が明らかにしたかったことそれはありふれた風景というものが
さまざまな要素の影響を受けてできているということです
このことを北海道弁で言い換えると作らせる風景というふうに言い換えることが出来る
かなと思います
耳馴染みのない方もいらっしゃると思うので少し細くすると作ると作ら去るという言葉
の関係は刺すと刺さるという言葉の関係に似ていると思います指に針を刺すという
いうと意図的に意思を持って針を刺したというニュアンスを受け取ると思いますが
指に針が刺さったというと意図せずふいに自己的に刺さってしまったような状況を
思い浮かべるのではないでしょうか
ありふれた風景のほとんどは風景を作る目的はなく
出来上がったものです
これらの風景を僕は対象として扱うことでその背景にある
例えば産業とか
と家の中にある生活やフード
自然環境や気候など様々な要素によって
風景が現れるということを明らかにしてきました
ではこの作ら猿風景というものが
冒頭でお話しした風景がないつまり認識されない状態のままでいいのかということを
最後に少しだけお話ししたいなと思いますひとつ
ゲームのようなものをしたいと思いますこれは僕が実際にある場所で撮った写真なん
ですけれども
払い
良い番組の8秒でこの写真を記憶してみてください
少し問題を出したいと思います
僕が実際に行ったある外国の街で撮った
おそらくありふれた風景かなというふうに思うんですけども
はい問題です赤い看板は何枚あったでしょうか
手前の道はいっぽうつうこうだったでしょうか
乗用車以外にどんな車がいたでしょうか
こう言われて明確に頭の中に回答を想像できた人は多くはないんじゃないかなという
ふうに思います
ちなみに答えは赤い看板は2枚すべての道が一方通行で乗用車以外にはタクシーと
トラックがいました
なぜ出さないかというと思いても問題があるからです
では今の写真
整然とした雰囲気だったか雑然とした雰囲気だったかそれとも自然的だったか人工的
だったか
アジア的だったか欧米的だったかと言われると多くの人は頭におおよそ共通した
イメージを抱いているんじゃないかなというふうに思います
これで何が言いたいかというと人間は情報の87%諸説ありますが
87%を視覚から得ているというふうに言われています
しかしその資格といっても細かいところを覚えるのが得意というわけではありません
大谷その雰囲気や代替のその場所のイメージというものを読み取ることが得意という
性質があります
そういう中で僕が大将としてきたありふれた風景は
じゃあ本当に風景がなかったのかということが僕のといいです
私は風景という直接見る対象のものを研究で取り扱ってきました
それによって僕の人生は前よりも豊かになったように感じます
それはなぜかというとどこを歩いていても見知らぬ場所に言ってもいろいろなものを
読み取れるようになったからです
僕は風景というものを研究していたからそういう目を獲得できましたがそれ以外にも皆
さんにもおそらく多くの特技があってその特技に応じて見る目というものは養われて
いるように感じます僕が研究の中で出会った農家さんは
この農場を見てこの作物が品種が何かというものを言い当てるだけではなく
この作物がミネラル不足なのかとか言ったことまで僕はまったくわからないですが
読み取ることができます
僕の友人の動物を研究している人は雪に残る動物の足跡を見て
何の動物かということを言い合ってているだけではなく場合によってはどういう行動を
している途中かということまで読み取ることができます
つまり多くの人にとってその自分の目
自分のオリジナルの目を使うことで風景を読み取ることができるのです
風景のない街は風景が認識されていない待ちでした
僕が出会ったすべての街に本来は風景がありますし僕の目から見ればいろいろなことが
分かるように多くの人からそれぞれの視点で風景を見ることができます
風景がない街を風景のある町に帰るのは一人一人の見方次第だというふうなことに気が
つきました
ありふれた風景からさまざまなことを読み取れるようになった僕が人生が豊かになって
このようにこのような場に立たせてもらえるようになったように皆さんも皆さんの目で
風景を見ることで皆さんの人生を豊かにしてぜひ風景がない街を風景がある町に
か
いる取り組みに参加してほしいなというふうに思います本日はありがとうございました
[拍手]